astronomie teams weltweit rätseln
fieberhaft wie das mysteriöse gamma
glühendem herzen der milchstraße und
vieler anderer galaxien zustande kommt
handelt es sich etwa um sich auslöschen
dunkle materie oder gar um pulsare ein
schottisches forschungsteam hat jetzt
eine andere erklärung dafür parat einen
eigentlich ganz und gar unmöglichen
effekt denn diese so genannte cherenkov
strahlung besteht aus schnellen teilchen
die sogar photonen also lichtteilchen
überholen dabei kann im vakuum doch
eigentlich nicht schneller sein als das
licht klicks um science fiction die
gibt's täglich faszinierendes 1 videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nichts herzlich willkommen im großen und
ganzen geht es bei dieser neuen
erkenntnis des schottischen
forschungsteams um das sogenannte sharon
yankov licht eine äußerst energiereiche
strahlung die entsteht wenn licht in
einem medium abgebremst wird und die
geladenen teilchen schneller fliegen als
das licht das ganze kann man
beispielsweise in einem wassergefüllten
reaktorgefäß von atomkraftwerken sehen
hier flitzen die elektronen superschnell
durch das wasser so schnell dass das
licht welches von den angeregten atom
abgegeben wurde nicht hinterherkommt es
entsteht eine art kiel welle 1
überschall schall also über lichtkegel
aus licht diesen sogenannten jankow
licht wird den neuesten erkenntnissen
zufolge sogar im vakuum das als erzeugt
und das ist wirklich paradox und zwar
durch die sogenannten
quantenfluktuationen des vakuums diese
sorgen dafür dass im vakuum immer wieder
neue virtuelle teilchen erzeugt wenn
paare aus antiteilchen und teilchen die
äußerst kurzlebig sind und sich direkt
nach ihrem auftauchen wieder auslöschen
das ist wirklich ziemlich mysteriös
passiert aber wirklich die entstehung
von materie aus dem nichts
laut der quantentheorie ist das wagnis
als also alles andere als leer
die fachleute aus schottland haben jetzt
ein modell entwickelt nachdem die
trennkost strahlung auch im vakuum das
als entstehen kann ein starkes
magnetfeld sorgt den expertinnen und
experten zufolge dafür dass die
virtuellen teilchen der
quantenfluktuationen licht abbremsen
dies führt also zu licht aus dem nichts
dazu heißt es in der studie
das impliziert das energiereiche partie
kleben als auch jeremy copp strahlung
freisetzen können wenn sie durch starke
elektromagnetische felder fliegen in
ihrer arbeit haben sie ganz genau
analysiert welchen bedingungen nötig
sind damit dem vakuum tschernjakow licht
freigesetzt wird konkret ging es
beispielsweise um die notwendige
feldstärke und die geschwindigkeit eines
protons der mit gamma strahlung frei
wird dabei handelt es sich eben um
sharon corr pflicht und das ergebnis ist
wirklich eine super spannende erkenntnis
denn das licht aus dem nichts ist wohl
vor allem in der nähe von schnell
rotierenden neutronensternen im starken
magnetfeld sogenannten millisekunden
pulse an vorstellbar dazu schreiben die
fachleute für protonen der
energiereichsten kosmischen strahlung
wird dort die hoch energetische
abstrahlung vollständig vom trainieren
kaufprozess dominiert diese ergebnisse
der studie passen übrigens gut zu bisher
gemachten beobachtungen beispielsweise
dem sekunden pulsen die aufgrund der
gammastrahlung aufgespürt werden konnten
jetzt geht die spannende suche erst
richtig los gesucht werden also
gammastrahlen die durch diesen vakuum
cherenkov effekt erzeugt wurden
denn solch eine entdeckung könnte den
endgültigen beweis für diese neue
theorie liefern auch das rätsel um das
äußerst mysteriösen kammer grün im
zentrum vieler galaxien und der
milchstraße könnte endlich gelöst werden
denn auch hierfür gibt es bislang keine
eindeutige erklärung auch wenn bislang
vom pulsare und auslöschen dunkle
materie als mögliche kandidaten
gehandelt wurden das forschungsteam
selbst ist optimistisch mit ihrem modell
weitere spannende erkenntnisse zum
generieren dazu der autor tino
jaschinski unsere theoretische
vorhersage ist sehr spannend denn sie
könnte antworten auf einige grundlegende
fragen liefern darunter auch nach dem
ursprung des gamma glühendem herzen von
galaxien gleichzeitig bietet er eine
neue möglichkeit fundamentale theorien
an ihre grenzen zu bringen und so zu
testen
der quantenphysik verstehen will der
kann das hier tun konnten für sich die
grundlagen quanten teil eins bei doktor
watson anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran